good morning everybody as you can see
I'm not looking into the camera I'm
listening to take your joy right now
it's funny I listen to like David Troy's
music it makes me want to die not
because it's bad because this music is
so emotional it always hits me in the
fields the song that he wrote is called
MC Hill if you guys don't know david
choi davidchoimusic he writes produces
does all of his own stuff and that's
like a real musician a lot of the
youtubers that you see that through
their music you know they constantly
only do covers that's it and when it
comes to doing their original music they
can't create it themselves they can
barely write these themselves like if
you want to be a signed artist and you
wanted somebody to pick you up and you
want it to be a product and that's what
it is
but if you're an any artist and you
can't do things for yourself then what's
the whole point of going the indie route
the point but just kidding news as
always let's see the type of mess that
we get in today if later on tonight I
ask you to be my girlfriend it's funny
cuz his wife was like in the beginning
of the vlogs
she just starts complaining that their
hotel doesn't have that you know Do Not
Disturb thing and she's like bitching
about it I'm like man she's like the
exact opposite of KC where's the food
Do Not Disturb sign what is the matter
of day well come on let's go I'll tell
me what if that's a character to create
that contrast maybe that's what we do
for sure that's not true you're a
natural [ __ ] you're just naturally like
know what you're talking about
he literally just like walks it's almost
like you're walking around that
documentary style nobody was doing that
before him prior to it yeah and I people
saw it like value in what he was doing
and he took his model yeah this setup is
this yeah I bit this off of him like I
said have bitten off him he has like
there he has a cute ass Joe be the one
bigger than this yeah a 70d and a
[ __ ] road like and he had a mic
because only walked when he seemed in
the shadows okay that [ __ ] shadow is
Canada just crazy like he's volume with
a red camera everywhere that he goes it
blows my mind crazy on our kingdoms
channel me and Charles you know Charles
yeah yeah
we also charted
stupid ass talk show about dance world
stuff Oh Delbert Randolph called on the
kini channel called Tina's combos city
is pretty much populist you guys pick on
him I don't know you don't you just pick
on him home you still see those comments
huh
I saw it's full out like literally just
driving down freakin Atlantic the other
day you know somebody in a car like
pulls up gets out and goes let me get a
photo with you and I'm like whoa like
but you guys had even window
Buddhism what about zero back just ever
get annoyed if you play the victim yeah
that's what's all here she limits it she
goes okay it's been an hour she's like
she's like can you learn the song and
then play it cuz like I was a practicing
happy birthday and I was like and then
so she would hear that over and over and
she's like can I can I listen to it like
when you get it down and then you can
never do it
to stay in Mystic tokenistic Eng
tokenistic Captain Morgan dressed
everything I never officially had them
subject honor right yeah cuz Jill is
doing a lot of the backend stuff yeah
but like in terms of managing like
getting deals and kind of picking your
big deals I think we never had anyone
like that yeah because he believed in
your brand a lot so that's pretty tight
man that's what you need any understands
like the industry so he when he was not
William Morris he helped usher get his
watch deal he helped between the teeth
look at this covergirl deal and all that
stuff this is all that stuff it takes
years he goes you mean with the CMOS of
these company like when we met with
Movado he's trying to like pitch my
shirt and then the CMO like the six year
old white guy so these are just talk
about the RV singer that guy he goes no
he's a [ __ ] megastar he's an icon
like everyone knows who the [ __ ] are
sure is like this one like so for him
it's like a continuous process and it
takes years before they can book
anything so he understands that so for
him he's like he's always down to fight
and push for free and kind of like pull
the right strings to make everything
connect once it does that's when it's
explosive I was just finished believe me
I don't usually do these thanks open oh
this drink got me singer thanks thanks
from when I read over this door would
you really wants the hoenn is crap
really good he buys all the necessary
tools and he actually use one gone we
had like crazy lenses like filters mom
what is this is this so that you can
hold it better so this is a Joby
Gorillapod
so if any of you guys out there I have a
product anyone let me put myself for six
yeah yeah
I don't have the next columns from a
1020 everybody so I go wider than Oprah
or some like Chevy's but a Joby
Gorillapod is a pretty girls like mom
you might actually have a few of these
in your option on why you're so
utilizing but they can wrap around
anything so if you guys are you
traveling photography or videography and
you need something that you could put on
real quick Joby Gorillapod look great so
number one they have rubber feets
right so when you land them down super
sturdy let's say you're going around and
you want to you don't have something to
place it on and you have a chair or
something like that
you're a Joby Gorillapod which is pretty
dope
godmother behave tell me he be things
like crucial nights when I'm right on
their patron talking closer toxic kids
so who's your girl